- [Jeanne] I wanted to kick off
with a question that I had on my own.
And that is, you know,
it sounds like the model,
even, you know, there
were these four scenarios
where you showed these certain curves.
And even with the strict
social distancing,
you still see a resurgence of the disease
sort of down the road,
like closer to December.
Those curves were still
coming up later on.
So, do you mind going back to that slide?
- [Chloé] Sure.
- [Jeanne] Just so that
everybody can visualize it.
- [Chloé] This one?
- [Jeanne] Yeah. So, curves
three and four, right?
So those are with the strict
social distancing measures.
You know, are those, I
guess my question is around,
you know, what is the value
of social distancing now
if you're only going to
see those peaks take place,
but just at a later date?
- [Sinead] Yeah, so that's
a really great point.
I guess one of the key values is that
if you can delay it enough,
you can give governments
more time to respond and
something we also didn't mentioned is you
can give researchers more time
to start looking into
different therapeutics,
maybe start looking for vaccines.
So that's one thing.
You get more time to prepare so that
when it does eventually come around,
you may have a better outcome
because you are more prepared.
But another, probably an
important assumption about
this paper is that when
that research happens,
they don't implement any new
social distancing measures
or any new kind of controlled measures.
And so they just let things play out.
But in reality, what would probably happen
is that once you start
to see it increase again,
you may have governments that start to put
more restrictions back
in place just to try
and keep things a little
bit under control.
Yeah.
- Great. Thank you.
So, I think that was a really important,
like buying time, I think, is the key.
- [Pedro] Yeah, that makes complete sense.
Okay, and with that I think
we'll start going into
some of the questions that
our audience submitted
both through Zoom and Facebook.
And we have a first question that
was submitted by Rosalie here on Zoom.
And she says that this feels that
they're changing two variables at once
by adding different types of S.D.
but changing times as well.
Why not do one at a time and
for the same amount of time
before varying the time?
Does that make sense?
- Yeah, I think, so, here for example
for curve three and four,
it's actually the same
social distancing rules
but they implemented time by saying
for this third case we're going to stop
at the end of March and the other one
is going to be at the end of April.
So they actually, I don't know if that
answered the question, but it's like
for the same social distancing rules,
but with a different time of the end
of the social distancing rules.
- So, they don't change
them at the same time,
they changed them in each group?
So, you know, the difference between
three, two, one are the increasing
amount of social distances and then
the difference between
three and four is the time.
They're not being
changed at the same time.
- Yeah, it's just, it's this line
that Sinead presented where it's the same
social distancing rules,
but one is just ending
one month after the other.
So, if you compare those two scenarios,
you're still comparing the same
social distancing measures,
but what happens if we keep it,
... we could do.
- [Pedro] And between two
and three, for example,
the time also did change
a bit or is that not true?
- Yeah, so in between two and three,
they assume that we keep the
social distancing measures
one additional month and
we're even more strict
by also adding this
general social distancing.
So it's true that in between two and three
you're like jumping a
lot because you're adding
one month of measures and
they're even stricter.
- Yeah. And I think that was the problem
that Rosalie was alluding to,
was that in that particular jump,
you're actually changing a
lot of variables at once.
- [Chloé] Yeah. And
actually what you can see
from the result is by having more strict
socially distancing measure, you can,
here you see you decrease
the value of the peak.
So the number of infected people
you're going to have at the peak.
But, if you just delay by one month,
by keeping the same measures,
you're going to have the
same value of the peak,
you're just delaying the peak.
- Yeah. So the time just delays it,
but the amount of social distancing
measures reduces the number of cases.
- [Chloé] Yeah.
- [Pedro] That makes sense.
- And I also think it's worth noting
that, you know, when we think about
experimental evaluation in
like a laboratory setting,
it's a very controlled environment.
When we talk about public health,
none of our lives is happening in
a controlled situation or in a vacuum.
And I think that makes
the data a little messy
just inherently, because of the fact that
you can't control for,
there's no control for human life, right?
And so, we all do what we're going to do.
So I think, you know,
for these types of data,
it's tricky overall.
Okay. So we have a question from Anissa.
And the question is,
what happens if people come out too early
and how does free moving
restrictions too early
lead to more people dying
or going back to phase one?
And which I think might be
quite sort of explained here in this.
But maybe you can go
through it for Anissa.
- Yeah, so once you
release these restrictions,
is when, you know,
people start moving about
as normal again and they can come into
contact with each other just as much
as they could before those
rules were put in place.
And so, you have the
contact rate among people
starts increasing again
and like we showed,
that means that the
transmission rate will increase.
And that's why you can get
another increase in cases.
So for example, the, you know,
the orange or the yellow lines here.
The rules were taken out
and it did take a while
for the cases to increase again,
but you do see that a few months later,
you see that second wave
because there's no more
controlled measures in place.
- Okay, great.
And third question from
Ann Sophie who is asking,
why the curve
with the strictest model
looks initially higher than the others.
- I'm not sure that it does.
- [Pedro] No, I think initially
higher before it goes down,
I guess, there's a little
bleep there in January.
- [Jeanne] Oh, I see.
- [Pedro] That's probably
before the measures start
getting put in place, but I don't know if
Chloe, Sinead, do you
want to address that?
- Yeah, so that's well-spotted.
But I think what's actually happening is
it's more of a plotting issue,
so I think the orange
line and the yellow line
are probably on top of each other.
And what you're (mumbles) the yellow line.
Because, yeah, it's before
the measures were in place,
so everything's happening the
same in those two scenarios.
So it's just that you can't
see the line below it.
- Great, thanks. So Juan was wondering
if we can elaborate on the impact of kids.
So they had trouble
understanding the logic
behind why more cases would
be averted if children,
I guess if there was social distancing
incorporated for schools and nurseries.
But, I guess the assumption
that Juan is making
is that children are less infectious.
Is that, maybe can you
elaborate on that a little bit?
- Yeah, so the assumption
they make in the paper
actually is that people
who are asymptomatic
are less infectious
because they assume that
if you have less symptoms
then you're less likely
to transmit diseases,
which may not be true,
but that's an assumption that they make.
And so they assume that
because we haven't observed
that many cases of
children, then children are
more likely to be asymptomatic
and so they're more likely
to be less infectious.
So that's what happens in this graph.
And so you avoid more cases
because you have less transmission,
for example, occurring in the household.
So by keeping people home,
even if you close the school,
you still have interactions between adults
and children in the households.
And if children are less infectious,
then they transmit less diseases
to the adults around them or
the other children around them.
So I think that's why
they avoid more cases.
And you can also avoid more
cases in the older people
because it's likely that
sometimes, you know,
children live with their grandparents,
or things like that, and
so you'll avoid cases.
And one thing that
Sinead mentioned is that
at the end of the social distancing,
people go back to normal.
So kids still go to school
and you can still have transmission.
So if children are less infectious,
then the transmission in the school is
less likely to happen I guess.
- Okay. I think we have
a question now about
your actual work from
Lauren who loves calculus
and who's wondering if and how
you use calculus in your work.
- I can say quickly. So
basically what we do is,
or what I've done
previously, is instead of
looking at people, we look at cells.
And so we use the same type of models
that we're looking at cells in your body
and, for example, when you
are infected by a virus,
cells are acting in your
body to react to the virus.
And a lot of things are happening
and we could look at
the dynamic of the cells
in the same way we could
look at dynamics of people.
And we're trained to understand
those dynamics with mathematical models.
- So I would agree completely with,
I think Chloé described it really well.
And just that, you know,
there's lots of options
depending on what you're interested in.
You can use very similar models to look
at the spread of diseases,
you can look at cells becoming infected,
but you can also look at
things like population growth.
You can look at animal movements.
There's so many different
things that you can do
with math that I don't
think I was really aware of
until I left school
and started studying it
when I was older, so I
think it's really great
to be interested now and
there's lots of things you can do with it.
- So adding onto Lauren's question.
If a person is interested
in maybe learning how
to do this type of modeling,
either because they just have an interest
or maybe want to do this, you know,
as an education and career,
what types of maths do you think
they should try to hone in on?
Like, for example, is calculus more
or less valuable than say, statistics?
You know, as people who come from
those backgrounds in your training,
what arm of math was sort of
the most valuable for you?
- For me, I have a
background in mathematics,
like basic mathematics and then
when I started trying
to apply into health,
I realized I really needed
biostatistics and statistics.
So, I would not neglect that.
But, I'm a little bit biased because
I have a PhD in biostatistics.
So maybe I'm going to tell you that,
but some other people would
tell you something else.
But I think it's great to
have a first background
in mathematics and be interested in
biological health professions.
There's always a way to
find a master's degree
that does a little bit
more applied mathematics.
And then you'll find a lot of people
who are interested in your skills
to try and understand
and help understanding
biological processes
and mathematical skills
or bioinformatics or, you know,
even informatics is really useful.
So keep going that direction.
- Yeah, my background is math too.
And I really wish I had
taken more statistics.
But also, computer
coding is something that
I think both Chloé and I use all the time.
I probably do that more now
than I use my actual math knowledge.
So, if there's any way
you can expose yourself
to more computer coding, that's
also a great skill to have.
- It's so interesting that
you're separating statistics from math.
- [Pedro] I was thinking the same.
- [Jeanne] I would consider them sort of
statistics under the umbrella of math.
- [Pedro] Exactly.
- [Jeanne] So are you saying
that they're different?
- [Chloé] Is it good to go into that?
(laughs)
- Okay, okay. We can
talk about that later.
But, yeah that's really interesting.
All right, let's get back to the paper
so that we make sure everybody's
questions get answered.
So here's a question from Peggy.
And this is coming from Facebook.
And it's around starting
school in September.
Do you think that, you know,
when people are applying these models,
I guess maybe for Wuhan or
for even places in the
United States like New York.
Do you think, you know, opening up schools
in September is going
to impact any of this?
What are the models saying?
- I can start answering, I don't know if Sinead you have a—
I think we need more information.
Unfortunately, I don't
think we can predict now.
That's actually why the Columbia team
is only projecting in eight weeks
because a lot of things are changing,
whether it be the behavior of people
or the policies, or like lot of things.
So we need more information.
We also need more information
on how many people
are actually infected in the
country or in New York City.
So we need more testing
and that will also give us
a better idea of, you know, how much
the disease has spread in the city yet.
And based on this
information, maybe we can
reevaluate for the situation in September.
But I definitely feel like it's too early
to answer that question.
- Okay, all right. We'll
move on to the next one then.
And this is a little bit outside
of the scope of this paper,
but I still think we can
discuss this from Aileen,
who, you know, in your model
the different conditions
that people could have in
the model that was discussed.
You mentioned that people were not
infectious once they had recovered.
And Aileen was wondering if
that had been determined,
because she thought it was unknown.
- So, it's very true because I would say
it's unknown how long
people are infectious for.
So, you know, the model they assume
it's on average by the week,
but it, you know, it could
go up to maybe two weeks,
that's still definitely unknown.
But the idea that, you know,
the way we define recovered
is that you're no longer
infected and infectious.
So the definition of recovered
would say that, you know,
once you are in that recovered
phase, you are definitely
not going to transmit the disease anymore.
But, she's absolutely right.
It's unknown at what point
you will move into that stage
after you've infected
and become infectious.
- And obviously then a
different question is,
can people at that point
become infected again?
But I don't think that
that was really included in the models
that we were discussing.
That's a question for another paper.
- Also, for that question I would refer to
a previous D4P that was speaking
about how long immunity lasts.
And that's also something that can be
included in the model when we know more.
We can also assume that, you know,
a proportion of the population
is likely to be reinfected
if it's the case or not.
And that can be adjusted in the model.
But, if you want to
know more, go just watch
the D4P from last week.
- Well luckily that page is
live, so people can watch it
and engage with the discussion guide.
So we can share that with everybody here.
Okay, so we have another
question from Lauren.
And I guess this is getting
at the seasonal spread.
So how does the virus spread differently
when you're inside versus outside.
For instance, can people
spending less time
inside in the summer months
prevent the virus from
spreading so quickly?
If you know?
- All right. So I am not an expert.
I think a lot of it
depends on what happens
to the virus in the air once, you know,
somebody coughs or sneezes and
how the particles kind of disperse.
But, I think the general consensus
or thought at the moment,
is that being outside is,
you know, you may be less at risk
because the particles have
more space to diffuse.
But, yeah it's not my area of expertise
so I wouldn't be able to say definitively.
- Yeah, that's a very tough one to answer.
But, you know, I guess
there's still research
ongoing around all of this.
Now, correct me if I'm wrong.
But they did determine when
SARS or MERS first came out.
Were those seasonal by any chance?
- So, I think at least for SARS,
it wasn't around long
enough for us to tell.
But, so there are other
human coronaviruses
that actually circulate year-round.
So they're related to
the novel coronavirus.
But, they're the second leading
cause of the common cold.
So we've probably all had them a lot.
And those are seasonal and, you know,
there are higher numbers
of cases in the wintertime.
But it's, you know, it
could be that the new
SARS-CoV-2 is like that,
but we just don't have enough
information to tell right now.
- Yeah. So seems like we lost Chloé.
But I think the only reason is
I was going to suggest we go back to the
slide where you had the
graphs for the next question.
But I think we can
probably all remember it.
And the question is from Aaron.
And he's saying that
the maximum difference
between the peak height when
you compare scenario one
with scenario four is
about 20 percent or less.
And that the total area under each curve,
which is a concept that
you might want to talk about as well,
appears to be about the same.
So he thinks that this suggests that,
if assuming no effective
treatment is developed
by December, the total number of deaths
will actually be similar regardless of social distancing.
- So they don't have, they don't share
those exact numbers in the paper
of all the total numbers of infections is.
And so, yeah maybe I should go into,
so the total area under
the curve in those graphs.
So what each curve is plotting
is the number of new cases each day.
But if you were to add
up the number of cases
on each day for the
whole length of the time,
then that would be the
total number of cases
that you get over the whole
period that they're looking at.
And so that's essentially what
the area under the curve is
is all those cases added up together.
And so they may be very similar.
I think in the paper they
plot the total number
and they, you know, at December 2020
right at the end when they
stop their simulations,
there is a very slight difference between
some of the curves, but it's not that big.
And so, yeah, what that suggests is that
the total number of cases
there isn't much difference
between the scenarios, but you know,
I think the main point is that, you know,
even if that is the case,
it's really important to delay that peak,
because if you give people
more time to prepare,
it may be that in a couple months' time,
you find a therapeutic, or you know,
your hospitals are more
prepared so you can
actually have a better
impact when the peak starts.
So you may actually be
able to push down that peak
more than it is portrayed at the moment,
assuming that, you know,
everything's the same.
- Yeah, exactly. And
that the maximum number
of cases in one day being slightly lower
is obviously going to
make a big difference
in the, you know, hospital
capacity for that day.
- And as we sort of described before,
those peaks are taking
place at a much later date,
so the hope is that there's just more time
- [Pedro] To prepare.
- [Jeanne] For more
creative intervention. Yeah.
I love this question from Sophia.
And the question is around,
can the researchers
use data from the study
to map deaths due to COVID-19 over time?
So what would be required to clarify
the importance of social
distancing in these models?
- Wait, is it about the
data that we need to gather?
Or is it more about...
- [Jeanne] Yeah, I
guess. I think, you know,
we're in such early
stages of understanding
the impacts of social distancing, right?
So, what would help clarify,
what extra data or, you know, variables
are needed to really understand
how social distancing
is impacting the spread of COVID-19?
- Yeah, so I think we've been speaking
a lot about testing in the population.
Because now at the
moment, the observation,
we have about people were
infected is mostly through
people who are going to the hospital.
So, it's definitely useful
to have a better idea
of how many people are infected
in the population to better understand
how the virus has been
spreading in the population.
I think what some people
have been saying is that
we don't have a control because we don't
know what's happening when
the disease is, you know,
spreading if we don't do
the social distancing.
But, we have seen that countries who
haven't applied social distancing
have been having some issues,
which is definitely not a
control compared to like
what happened in New York, for example.
But it gives us insights on
also the dynamic of the epidemic.
And, also, like this
social distancing stuff
is something that we would apply
for any other disease
that's transmitted by air.
It's not just specific to COVID-19,
it's measures that have
been recommended by
experts for a long time.
I don't know if she knows
that's something to ask.
- No, I think, yeah.
- [Chloé] Yeah, cool.
- [Pedro] All right.
So this is a really
interesting question by Aditi.
So okay, if individuals
are easily reinfected
with the virus, and as we've
mentioned, that's a big if.
And again, you know, directing people
to last week's presentation.
Thank you Lizzie for
sharing the link for that.
But let's imagine hypothetically
that if individuals are easily
reinfected with this virus,
and they could then be infectious again,
how would this affect the R0 value
and the peak of the curve?
Is that something that could
be included in the model?
- Yeah so. Sorry, go ahead.
- [Sinead] No, I'm fine.
- [Chloé] So the R0 is
not going to be affected.
The R0 is what happens
if the disease is spread
in a population that's
completely susceptible.
So, it's something that
you would determine
most likely at the
beginning of the epidemic.
The effective or productive
number, the Re or Rt or R,
that Sinead mentioned, would
definitely be affected.
Because people would just be like,
instead of just being recovered
and not being reinfected,
they will go back to their
susceptible compartment.
And so that would definitely affect
the progression of the epidemic.
Yes, it would increase actually,
And we would need a vaccine or
a treatment to prevent that.
- So I'll ask the last question.
And I'm just going to sort of summarize
a couple of the ideas that
I see in our question chat.
And it's around the motion to, you know,
there's a lot of states that
are currently reopening.
And what we're finding is, you know,
some of the states that
are currently reopening
didn't necessarily have very strict
social distancing rules
in the first place.
And that could be for a
variety of different reasons.
And as they reopen, we're
also seeing things like,
you know, everybody's
going to the beach or
everybody's going to a
restaurant, you know.
What do you think that that's going to do?
Do you think that, you know,
are there models that can help people
sort of understand the consequences
of those actions in these granular ways?
And if so, you know, how
is that kind of information
important for policy makers to know
and sort of, Congresspeople to know?
Where do you see those intersections
of the modeling pieces and the people who
are making the rules for society?
I know that's a little
bit of a loaded question,
but I would love to hear
your thoughts on that.
- So, personally, I'm a little bit worried
about places opening up too soon.
Because, yeah, you know, cases may
look like they're kind of steady now,
but there's always a lag between
when things are implemented
and then when we actually
start to see cases turn up at the hospital
because of the long period between when
you start to show symptoms.
And so what may look like, you know,
things are going okay right now,
it could be that in a few weeks' time,
it's a different story.
Yeah, sorry I forgot
the rest of the question.
- Yes, like how are people engaging with,
are people like in your
field, for example,
or your lab group as an example,
are they engaging with policy makers or
people that are sort of
getting to say how people
behave in a society or community?
- I would say that I'm sure that people
who are modeling these things are trying
to engage with policy makers
and people at the government level
to try and help plan,
or at least I'm sure
people are communicating
the results of their model.
But then it's up to policy makers,
whether they want to implement, kind of,
the recommendations of the scientists.
Because obviously, there
are a lot of other factors
that go into these decisions.
And economic factors, and you know,
lots of other factors.
So, yeah.
- [Jeanne] Yeah, I
imagine it's very tricky.
Yeah, sorry, go ahead Chloé.
- [Chloé] No, I was just going to say
that we've seen decisions
that were based on models,
like a couple of months ago in UK.
Some decisions were
taken after the results
from a model were
published or like spread.
So, it's actually really happening,
which is good that, you know,
government are taking decisions
that are based on science.
And, again, as we said,
the models are going to
be refined by more data
and because we're learning
more about the disease.
So hopefully it will
help also in the future
to take, also, decisions that
are balanced between the other factors
and the number of people that have been
affected by the disease.
- Yeah, thank you. And I think with that,
if anybody's really interested in science,
but also interested in
public health and/or policy,
I hope everybody out here will consider,
you know, moving in those,
like, training in science and then
being a part of the government.
I mean, how amazing could it be to see
our government with people who value data
and the scientific, you know, enterprise.